x
de têtes que vivent
bien des parents.
Louis-Philippe Ouimet.
- Je veux des bonbons!
- Les enfants ça rit, ça tousse,
ça pleure et ça revendique et
tout ça parfois dans la même
minute. Pour Mani Soleymanlou,
père d'un garçon de six ans
et comédien dans la série
"Survivre à ses enfants",
la vie familiale n'est pas
toujours rose bonbon.
MANI SOLEYMANLOU, comédien
- La vie est devenue
de plus en plus stressante.
Les choses, les horaires sont
devenus de plus en plus
exigeants. Le travail ne nous
quitte pas des mains parce qu'on
est sur nos téléphones.
Malgré tout, je pense que la
série nous montre qu'à un moment
donné il faut tirer la plogue.
- Ok, puis t'es-tu correct?
- La série "Survivre à ses
enfants" met en scène trois
jeunes couples d'amis
apprivoisant au jour le jour
la vie familliale.
L'auteur Jean-François Léger,
qui a travaillé entre autres sur
les émissions "Un gars, une
fille" et "Les Parent",
a écrit, ici, une auto-fiction.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS LÉGER, auteur,
"Survivre à ses enfants"
- L'inspiration me vient
beaucoup de mes quatre enfants.
Je dis toujours à la blague que
ça été l'erreur de ma vie,
mais que j'essaie
de la rentalibiliser
en vampirisant mes enfants pour
mettre leur vie à la télévision.
- Appelle la police.
- Cette série de treize épisodes
de trente minutes a pris des
allures de catharsis pour la
comédienne Catherine Bérubé,
mère d'une fille de cinq ans.
CATHERINE BÉRUBÉ, comédienne
- C'est un peu spécial parce que
Annie est un personnage qui me
ressemble, j'aime dire
tristement beaucoup.
Je pense qu'elle va aller des
cordes chez beaucoup de parents.
- "Survivre à ses enfants"
aborde ces moments d'anxiété
pour tout parent de jongler avec
le travail et les tâches
familiales, tout en s'occupant
de ses enfants
et de son couple.
- L'humour nous a toujours servi
à dématramatiser les situations
durant notre vie. Ça serait
peut-être mon autre conseil de
dire, utilisez l'humour, parce
qu'on finit par passer à traver.
- C'est les enfants qui souvent,
nous apprennent à être
des parents. En tout cas, moi,
c'est comme ça que j'ai appris à
être père. C'est mon fils qui
m'a appris et non l'inverse.
- Je vous présente Philémon.
- Moi c'est la poutine
et les sous-marins.
- On pourra voir "Survivre à ses
enfants" dès le 22 juin sur ICI
TOU.TV